good evening it started with a missing
person's case and then ended with a
gruesome discovery of a woman's body in
the desert thanks for joining us here at
five o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus today marks another chapter
with the sentencing of Christopher
prestepino for murder he could serve 10
to 25 years behind bars eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
following the story and has the latest
from Court
Prince of Esmeralda Gonzalez her brother
says Christopher prestepino's sentencing
in connection with her murder does mean
some closure for the family it gives us
an opportunity to continue the healing
process just moments before we spoke
with Juan Gonzalez Madeira he shared his
personal story of loss in this Las Vegas
courtroom I now live in a world where I
only get to see my sister alive when I
dream at night and we live the nightmare
of her death when I wake up in the
morning as merelda Gonzalez was just 24
years old when her life was cut short in
2019 through a plea deal for
second-degree murder and kidnapping
Christopher prestopino will spend at
least seven years in prison before he
could go in front of a parole board
that's because he's given credit for
three years he's already spent Behind
Bars the maximum he could serve is 25
years still find it unbelievable that a
part of the situation but I apologize
sincerely prestepino entered in Alfred
plea not admitting guilt but admitting
there's enough evidence to convict him
he claims his roommate Cassandra Garrett
injected Gonzales with pool cleaner
police say they then placed her body in
concrete and dumped her remains in the
desert Garrett also took a plea deal
learning that my sister was deceased
deeply bruised my heart but learning how
she died
shattered my heart forever he recalls
their childhood his sister's goals like
becoming an attorney and how he thinks
of her as his guardian angel my sister
is and continue used to be the light
that shines Within Me Cassandra Garrett
is expected to be sentenced next month
reporting in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now